hey guys I'm sorry you haven't gotten a
video for me in a few days I've been
down in California visiting the schmoes
from schmoes no but at my first day down
there we went on the Fox lot we just
like pretty much loitered and we took
video of it so I wanted to show you guys
what we did it just does just jerking
around down there and so this is the
video of me going from rainy Washington
to sunny California to start it out like
this they hope you enjoy where the
hell's the Sun I left the sun's back in
Washington that's never happened in the
history of life ever it's shitty in LA
it's sunny in Washington so come and
join us guys as I know it likes when he
said it's like the expendables all over
again we should have thought about the
Sun thing dude
no years no we couldn't have got him out
here it's gone we're starting to get
nervous
it looks like more that's what we're
doing we're going to Mountain doom for
miles that way we're in Mordor let's go
your humps oh hi kids
root the Fox a lot this is where they
make God is where they make Fox movies
and we're here with our pals we're gonna
go look for anything that is related to
Star Wars preferably the the first three
yeah movies we'll need to see I think
charge artworks at the commissary he's
in the back kitchen so they will say out
of him if he's wearing a hairnet like
he's supposed to
nobody's perfect
that's the original
pretty damn cool it's true love
it really is oh my boy I have liked to
have shirts already actually just get a
third one have a trifecta of Awesome
this is my other house shirt it's not
really
housewares my shirts [ __ ]
plagiarizing bastard never had a chance
you know what the best thing about that
right there is it knows it's all
[ __ ] I'll and I get cast in this did
this always affects the garni Weaver
when you were younger
Thursday I always thought it was but she
was the last of the Mohicans hey Jeremy
happy birthday buddy that's the age
Jackie arrowy was when he would be
attracted to how old Jackie
Hillary is now in movie he plays
pedophiles in movies that's what I'm
saying the only high school picture of
me you have me no Hawaiian share in the
yearbook
you're not seeing anything that cool I
promise all right here here's the story
of The Simpsons my parents thought they
were too crude when I was little so I
had a little TV tuner for the game here
cuz I had a game gear because I have
that old school and you can watch TV on
it hey watch it
how's rebel that's the worst thing I
ever do to the kid
watching the synthesis oh you bet
greatest character in Simpsons history
is Hans Moleman because he starred her
actually though he was the inspiration
for the great Torcy scott classic man
getting hit in groin with football this
works because you were actually a
character in this film but Jeff but you
died before the good part at the end
when Hans Gruber fell off and we get a
shot of the Nakatomi Plaza please that
is probably the coolest thing I've seen
beside on the lawn let me just say that
the douches name his first name was
Ella's not his last name all right so
Jeremy is officially he's been here ten
minutes he's got Hollywood
so there it is guys we had a lot of fun
I had a good time with the schmoes and
atop the trip off after I was leaving
California I was that LA actually just
waiting there for like a couple hours
because that's what you do at an airport
waiting to go back to Washington this
guy just comes up to me he's like I know
you from somewhere he knew me from
YouTube so we just sat down and we
talked about you know like spider-man
and Dark Knight Rises and all that stuff
he was a cool guy and I love hearing
from you guys so there is that and I got
a few more vids coming to you guys one
would be in my conan review and the
others being collaboration as I did with
the schmoes vol movie preview two of
which I'll have on my channel you see
them coming right here two of which will
be on their channels - be sure to check
those out and there's actually a movie
that Mark Ellis is then called little
[ __ ] and Christian and I reviewed that
trailer because it's absurd it's like
the worst piece of [ __ ] you've ever seen
so keep an eye out for that video and I
got some movie reviews coming for you
for this weekend and I got pax this
weekend also so if you guys subscribe to
me just recently you subscribed at the
right time because I'm gonna take a lot
of videos and just shove them at your
face and the podcast in which the
schmoes interviewed me about I guess
main Q&A about me if you're interested
if you're curious that's coming up this
Saturday be sure to check that out and
there's two more podcasts coming out
after that in which I co-hosted with
them in which we interview Steve
Rannazzisi from the league and Serena
Vincent she was in cabin fever she's
been in a few horror movies and scary
movies so we interview her about horror
movies and scary movies and she's
honestly one of the greatest people I've
ever met my life she's so nice I didn't
know what to expect but she is like one
of the nicest people ever she impressed
me I like her in any case if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more as always click right here to see
more